thirty-five years after the worst
chemical leak to happen in India another
tragic accident has taken place a gas
leak from a factory causing hundreds of
people to flee their homes suffering
from severe breathing and vision
problems many of them collapsing on the
streets hundreds including children have
been rushed to hospitals in whatever
means of transport available the death
toll is rising and many are said to be
in critical condition overall I think
about 800 to 1000 people have gone to
the hospital and they have been taken
care of so now the focus is not so much
on the gas leakage as the effects of the
gas leakage and the treatment of the of
the people who have been affected
initial reports suggest styrene gas
leaked from the LG polymer factory based
in Vishakhapatnam industrial zone in the
southern state of Andhra Pradesh early
this morning the gas commonly used in
the manufacture of plastics is also a
neurotoxin and higher concentrations can
cause death thousands of people have
been evacuated from the nearby villages
and rescue teams from the National
disaster relief force are checking homes
for any survivors in a statement the
South Korean parent company LG Chem said
they are assessing the extent of the
damage and are doing all that they can
to help the residents and employees
today's gas leak is a reminder of the
1984 popplet gas tragedy one of the
world's worst industrial disasters
thousands of people died and over
600,000 affected decades later its
effects are still being felt as children
are born with disabilities to those
connected to the tragedy
Prime Minister Modi has held an
emergency meeting to monitor the
situation and offered all support from
the federal government an investigation
into what caused the leak
in launched there are reports that the
factory was being prepared to reopen
after the national lockdown but for now
all efforts are to rescue the injured
and get them to safety
never Lazarus Sky News India